lovu same here Evans del paraiso in
token linea de la folie I'd I can tell
you it RDV I say fed / i do feel i leap
him draw him Anastasio for me were a bit
lazy i have no duty blue blue gray said
anatolian to Europe Sox a win Alberto
man Fellig online I the right worship
for the Lord Mayor of the City and
County of Swansea from select a man
Thomas being the returning officer at
the election held on thursday the
seventh of may 2015 do hereby give
notice that the number of votes cast for
each candidate at the Swansea west
election is as follows Davis k-lite
Welsh Labour severe camry fourteen
thousand nine hundred and sixty-seven a
new pet will be now can't quit excite
Thord Martin UK Independence Party UK
4744 can one be tied down and wondering
Mr Colley Chris Welsh Liberal Democrats
3178 Democrat I'd prefer don camry three
mil in can't say i gueth Joe Donald
trade union unionist and socialist
coalition 159 in concluding now Johnson
Brian the Socialist Party of Great
Britain 49 had one dig no rush
Conservative Party candidate I'm
guessing playa de que duardo camry 7930
one size mute now can't treated you
Roberts Harry Flite camry the party of
Wales 2266 dou bu three hun with a twist
Rosa Maxwell and Iran's independent 78
sighs big boys we click Ashley James the
Green Party plied well 1780 yeah yes I
can Ethan Edwards a girl we've driven
and that gun for the United tvs with
your own Ethel and I hereby declare that
gay right Davis has been duly elected
thank you what a fantastic result for
this value right there I'd like to thank
all the people who've involved in the
camp the returning officer all the
counters who are still out of work the
police everyone who gets this place
moving I'd like to thank course my my
wife Vanessa my family for supporting me
I like to thank my agent tarik Roberts
and Simon dar boy these things are to
lead in the organization I'd like to
thank all the team you're all here
tonight from Swansea West Labour Party
who worked so hard to make this campaign
such a great success this has been a
marathon it hasn't just been a campaign
I've been working hard for the people of
swansea and my pledge today is to
continue to work for all the people of
Swansea all the communities all the
neighborhoods at everybody in Swansea
west to bring about a stronger and
better future for it all my ambition of
course was to raise the majority from
504 made 500 500 500 six-course the
majority has increased 14-fold to over
7,000 and I am privileged and pleased
and humbled
the better world with all of the hopes
for a better Britain and I very much
hope and expect to continue my role for
Swansea and thank you all and good night